here
It is great to be with you once again.
And I am especially excited about today. Not
just because it's seeing your
Sunday. I have a daughter who's a senior this this year as
well.
And so
You know, this is exciting time, right?
Life transition about to go Brave the the
world that you haven't known before about to go off to college.
These are exciting times and to all these seniors. I want
to commend you for your hard work.
I'm excited for you. I'll say it just like
I said to my daughter we believe in you.
And we believe what God can do in and through your life. So you're about
to kind of leave the nest so to speak and faith
and brave a brand new
world and in many ways a strange world, but
that's part of the fun right to go
to places. You've never been
To Adventure go into an adventure that you've never been a part
of and so I just want to let you know that.
We're praying for you. We believe in you and I know
this church family is going to be praying for you and cheering
you on as you go into your next steps.
These are strange days some of you have been asking. How
are you and how is OBU is doing very well.
We have about a 12 to 24 month overall recovery,
but I'm very happy to tell you that we
are back in classes on campus. We had
a big Community party yesterday. We had
live music we were able to do one of our shows, you
know, every year we do a show.
Where we have students who do performances and so
obviously because of tornado things were
had to be shifted a little bit but we
were able to do that in the lawn yesterday
outside our stadium and it
was absolutely a blast. So we had a few
hundred people there playing games
listen to live music and it was just such
a good reminder that God can renew even broken things
and that's what I've experienced in the past couple weeks
and I just want to encourage you that's what we can experience
as well. And in fact, that's where we are in
the Book of Joel we've seen in the early half of
the book.
words of judgment
But now we're in the part of the book that emphasizes restoration.
and renewal and in fact, we're in the second section today
in Joel 2:28 to 32 that
focuses on a promise
of restoration, but
Before I get there, I do want to
invite you. We do have an OBU alumni
friend perspective student luncheon. If you want to come it's
immediately after the second service. I believe it's in
the choir room. And I don't know we usually have really
good things to eat there and some fun things to take
away. I'm not sure exactly what
all is going to be there for you, but I'll be there and
I'd love to talk with you about what God's doing on bison Hill.
So if you're a prospective student or an alumni or a
friend or just an interesting party, or maybe you just want to free lunch,
that's fine, too.
You can come.
I'll see you there.
All right.
I've said that Joel that we're in this section of renewal. Let
me tell you a little bit about renewal renewal
is when something that is dilapidated or
something that is old or tired or something
that is about to die or maybe even dead
has come back to life. It's renewed.
Well, that's what we're talking about in Joel.
title of today's messages a call that saves now I
am a weird history buff my
periods of history that I like to study may seem
strange to some
Okay, I like ancient history by ancient history.
Let me be very clear what I mean. I like
ancient history 5,000 years ago to
about 300 BC,
right? So that's kind of a wide range
of ancient history. But then I also am a
history buff on World War Two history. Anybody
World War Two historians like to read on World War
Two.
Well, let me get that a little bit more specific. I like
to study The Life and Times of one
of World War two's major leaders, Winston
Churchill.
The British Bulldog, right, you know Winston Churchill
chomping on a cigar.
He was quite a character.
He would spend.
He would spend a lot of the morning.
in bed
with you know various things including the cigar
and he would dictate all these
memos.
But he was so eccentric but also so beloved.
And one of the things that we know about Winston Churchill
is in the time of his prime ministership.
One of the things that he did is he would
make regular calls, especially in the early days when
Britain was engaged in war with
Germany, he would make regular calls.
to our US President Roosevelt
and he would call and he would call and for a long
time. It was a different political world back
then in American politics America really
didn't want to get involved in the for in the second
world war. They didn't want to get involved at all and so Churchill using
all of his rhetorical skill would try
to convince Roosevelt and America that it
was in their interest to get involved in the war and he
would call.
from the cabinet War rooms
in London
He would call.
And he would call.
And Roosevelt was kind and would say all the
right things like we're with you buddy. He didn't say
buddy.
We're with you Mr. Churchill and very politicians speak. He
would say, you know all of our heart.
Is for the British people right and all those things?
But there was a turning point.
In the Turning Point happened after the attack on
Pearl Harbor.
when
Churchill made a call
and he said, you know, Mr. Roosevelt.
I'm so sorry to hear about the terrible attack.
and at that point
all of the calls that had gone before
that were ineffective.
That call was a call that saved why once
America got into the world war and you
can see this in Churchill's writings. Here's the reality.
He knew once America got into the
world war.
Essentially the Allied Forces would be victorious.
And sure enough they were that call.
After Pearl Harbor was a call that saved
why America was the great sleeping
giant.
reticent to get into war but once they got into war
it was the endgame.
I want to talk about a call that saves.
And I'm not talking about a call that saves in a World War.
I'm going to talk about a call that saves in the war for your soul
and for mine.
And Joel opens us up.
to the call
that saves
So if you have your Bible turn to Joel chapter 2.
We're going to begin in verse 28 and go all
the way to the end of the chapter 2 verse 32.
So the text reads this.
after this
I will pour out my spirit on all Humanity.
Then your sons and your daughters will prophesy your
old men will have dreams in your
young men will see visions.
I will even pour out my spirit on male and female
slaves in those days.
I will display wonders in the heavens and on the Earth.
Blood Fire Columns of smoke the sun will be
turned to Darkness and the moon to blood before the
great and terrible day of the Lord
comes, press pause.
Once again, we have this emphasis in the Book of Joel about
the the day of the Lord and as I've said the day of
the Lord.
Is an event where God reveals himself?
in judgment and/or salvation for Israel
and/or the nations in accordance with the justice and
the mercy of God, so we're talking about
Here a big time day of the
Lord where God reveals himself.
In both judgment and salvation for who?
Well, we'll talk about that.
Okay.
But this day of the Lord.
Is kind of like what we saw in chapter one The Day of the Lord
comes with Cosmic events.
here
we have Cosmic upheaval.
Right the sun's darkened.
the Moon
blood red
it looks like everything is topsy turvy. So
there's Cosmic phenomena with the day of the Lord verse
32 then everyone who
calls on the name of the Lord will be saved.
For there will be in.
For there will be an escape for those on Mount
Zion and in Jerusalem as the Lord promised amongst
the survivors that the Lord calls.
This passage helps us understand a call
that saves now. I just want to offer two Reflections from
this passage and then bring it home to us. Okay?
So what I'd like for you to do is hang on with me first reflection that
we see from this passage of scripture is quite simply this and
it may not seem immediately obvious, but I want you
to walk through this with me.
First thing we see in this passage listen to me is God
wants us to experience
him.
God wants us to experience him.
Now how many of you live by a calendar?
Anybody let me see some hands anybody live by calendar.
I do.
In fact, I've got mine pulled up right here.
my calendar
is full from about 6:30 until about
8:30
because it's a heavy time right now.
Not 6:30 in the morning to 8:30 in the morning. That would be a good day.
Right. These are long days. My days are filled according
to a calendar.
I have a lot of events on the that calendar.
And sometimes if you live by a calendar and students you're
about to go to college or you're about to go into the workforce. You'll
find out very quickly. It's a little bit different than High
School.
You're living according to a calendar that's really imposed on
you in a way that's never been imposed before.
And so you have you know, Monday Wednesday Friday classes at this
time this time and this time you get Tuesday Thursday classes.
You might not have night classes.
Some of you are working you have a work schedule that you've got to live
by.
And sometimes when we live according to our calendars we move from
events.
to events
to events to events and we're grinding down
into powder.
events
I'm tired of events.
I don't like events.
In fact, I was telling our our Student Government leadership early
last year.
I said, you know, we've got a lot of events going on at
OBU. I'm tired of events.
Aren't you tired of events?
Just going from thing to thing.
my goodness events
What we need to move from is from events to
experiences why because an
event doesn't change your life.
Events beat us down but an experience.
Well an experience can change your life.
I remember the first time I went trout fishing with my dad.
You know I had been fishing before.
Lake Ray Hubbard and all sorts
of lakes and Dallas Fort Worth area
It was fine. I got some bubble gum out of it was good. Yeah,
I Like It Outdoors. Yay.
But when I went trout fishing for the first time in the Smoky Mountains
Hiking through the mountains climbing on rocks seeing copperhead
snakes.
Not getting bit by them.
I remember the first time, you know, I was I was fishing and I
saw a black bear. First of all, that's scary.
But you know how I know it wasn't just an event on the
calendar of my young life. I still try out fish today.
In fact in a little while. I have planned and God
willing I'll be able to do it.
Take my boys.
After the semester to go trout fishing and they love
to do it, too. We're gonna go back to the Smokies.
So an experience changes your life.
Now listen to me.
What God desires for you and me is not an event
on the calendar.
God wants for you and me to experience.
him
you say what?
How do you know?
Because the Bible tells me so.
Check this out.
in Joel 2:28 to 32
God points to the fact that he doesn't want
us to just have an a time
like a worship service or something like that where we
kind of experience something and sing some songs. No,
he wants us to encounter and experience
him. So our lives are fundamentally changed.
Why because did you notice?
In verse 28 what happens look at this?
What does it say after this? I will pour out
my spirit.
And when the spirit comes God's people who have
this Spirit encounter guess what's going to happen?
They are going to prophesy.
the spirit
is the empowering presence that God
gives to his people so that they may know him
when we look at Joel 2:28 to
29. We see that this text has some
kind of connection using similar
language to other prophetic texts.
Like in Isaiah and Ezekiel, here's the difference between
Isaiah's use of the spirit
and ezekiel's use of the spirit.
In Joel what we've got here was when the spirit comes God's
people are gifted to prophesy.
prophesy
So like in Isaiah, this is interesting.
In Isaiah when the spirit comes God's people are enabled to
you know, follow his commands and follow his words
Divine instruction. This is Isaiah 59:21 in
Ezekiel 36 God's spirit is poured out.
So that God's people can follow God's judgments and statutes.
in Ezekiel 37 when the spirit comes
God gives life to his people but in Joel.
When the spirit is poured out.
God's people actually speak God's word like Prophets
The Spirit in Joel 228-29 enables God's
people to do the work of Prophecy. And what does
that actually mean? What does it mean when you see like Joel
and these other prophets prophesy?
Deborah there's a lot of prophets and prophetesses in
the Old Testament.
It means that God enables his people to
experience him listen to this.
Personally, you know who's the consummate prophet in the Old Testament Moses? And
you know what the Bible says about Moses?
Moses saw God face
to face Abraham's called the prophet
You know what Abraham experienced. Well the Book
of James tells us.
That Abraham was a friend of God.
Who's your best friend?
Who's your closest friend?
What do you do with your friend when you get into a tough time? What do you
do you call them?
Who's your closest friend you laugh together you cry together you do
stuff together. You have a lot of fun together.
You can fight in one another Abraham the consummate prophet
in the Old Testament with Moses is called a
friend of God.
No, God personally.
experience him personally
to hear his voice like a friend.
And then speak God's word to those who need to hear it. That's what prophets do.
So when you think about Experiencing God, it's not just having
an emotional experience.
It's
Hearing God's word.
Like a friend as he gives you guidance.
and direction in life
as he reveals truth.
So that then you can live it but also Proclaim it.
So this outpouring of the spirit described in
Joel is powerful.
Because it's personal.
It's experiential.
It's intimate.
It's real.
And then God empowers us to speak his word to those who need
to hear it.
And this is an interesting reality in
the Book of Joel now in the Book of Joel you'll notice that it's God's
Representatives who speak God's word in
chapter one. We saw this. Do you remember this in chapter
one when God's people cry out? It's the priests.
Who go before the people?
And they lead the people in crying out to God. So the priests
are the one Speaking the word of
God. Did you see that impedance? They're going to
the temple and they're saying on behalf of the people and Leading the People.
Hey God, this is what's going on the priests.
They repent of the temple with the priests the people do at the
with the priests at the lead. They repented the
temple and the the priests are at the front of
the procession
but check this out.
That form of worship is hierarchical. Did you
see that?
The priests are at the head.
The priests are doing all the talking.
What's interesting here?
Is when the spirit of God is poured out.
This is a huge contrast to what we've seen before.
When God's spirit comes upon all people here in
Joel 2:28 to 32. There's no hierarchy.
All people are imbued with the spirit of God in the gift of
Prophecy and vision from the Lord this picture. Let me
just say Accords with the New Testament image of God's
people becoming the spiritual house.
the temple
what is the text say after this? I will pour out my
spirit on who the rich? No, that's
not what it says.
I know the good looking. No, that's not what it
says. Oh, I know the priests and the most holy
people that's not what it says.
It says that I will pour out this is God speaking my spirit
on all Humanities some of your versions
say All Flesh.
And when he does this your sons and your daughters, I know
who will up speak God's word and receives a spirit.
I know it's only going to be you know, the spiritually mature and
not the Young. No.
Young
here your sons and your daughters will prophesy your old
men will have dreams your young men will see visions.
Seeing visions having dreams speaking words of God.
That is the function definition of prophecy.
And intimate relationship with God wherein he encounters
you and you experience him and then all the
sudden you're for claiming God's word. You're gaining Insight
you didn't have before this is the outpouring of the spirit.
This is a renewal.
I even like this idea that
It's unbelievable. And it's hard sometimes when we read
verse 29. I will pour out my spirit on the male and
female slaves in those days.
You might say well, I don't like that slavery in the bible stuff, right?
Read the book of fleeman, you'll see there's a progression out of it. You know,
that's the way that works.
But you know, there's something about this male and female slaves.
These could be indentured servants of who
are fellow Israelites, but it also could be
captured slaves who were non-israelites
in the midst of Israel, and if that's the case then non-israelites you
Call these Gentiles.
in the New Testament
not Israelites also received the
gift of Prophecy.
the experience with God
Israelites non Israelites Jews gentiles
God wants all to experience
him.
now
If that's true.
my friends
it points to this fact that God doesn't just want some
to know and experience him.
He wants all to come and know to
experience him.
The spirit reveals the truth that God wants us to experience
him intimately.
personally
like prophets we hear God's voice speak God's word. This is
God's desire. Not just for a few. It's for
you and for me least to the greatest young old able-bodied
and those with disabilities different backgrounds
different social classes different ethnicities. God
wants to pour out his Spirit on all Humanity.
Sometimes we think that God really wants to
know some of us the good the perfect.
the nice
only those who go to church
Joel too reminds us that God because he
loves us.
wants to pour out his Spirit on all
some of us might think well God doesn't really need me. He just wants to
bless the needy the poor.
Those in need maybe another lands.
But that's not pictures that we get here.
God wants you to experience him. God
wants me to experience him
because of the radical love of
God this phrase. God will pour
out his Spirit on All Flesh all Humanity
upon male and female sleep slaves indicates
that God is no respecter of persons.
He loves.
And he wants to pour out his spirit and what is the spirit? Why the
spirit?
The spirit empowers us to hear God's voice.
to know God
to discern truth from error
And to speak God's word with power. See God wants.
All to experience him.
I think about this.
radical transformation that comes from Experiencing God
and I think about one of our students.
Who experienced God in a special way?
This this past semester.
She grew up in church.
And she was actually one of our volleyball players unbelievable athlete
very tall.
And she's also an artist singer.
unbelievable
But like many of us, you know, she might have grown up in church,
and she was just kind of wandering around going from this
relationship to that relationship.
God was kind of a feature in her life, but not really personal.
experiential
and what happens?
in a Revival
You know a couple of weeks after the Asbury Revival.
When God began to move on our campus and we saw
lives changed and we saw worship
Unleashed and we saw the Lord getting
hold of people and they were responding students
were responding and we had worship services that lasted hours
and hours in the in the
the hours of the class and hours of the
day, but also deep into the night.
This student told her mother and she was a little bit skeptical on
church because of some of the pain and some
of the things that she had experienced.
As she kind of rebelled against the Lord.
just skeptical
But she told her mother. I don't know what's going on at OBU,
but something's happening to me.
God's getting hold of me.
And what happened? I don't know how else to explain it.
She experienced God.
And her life was changed.
Few days after the Revival she gave
a testimony in Chapel.
And she said those of you who knew me before?
If you told me that I would be speaking in Chapel
about what God's done in my life. Nobody would have believed it. I wouldn't believed
it.
But this is her testimony.
I don't know how to tell you this.
But I am transformed.
How does that happen?
when we experience God
when we hear the call of God on our life.
And my friends when we give our heart and Life to Jesus Christ.
He gives us his spirit.
We hear his voice.
like a friend
in our lives
are
changed
our tongues
are loosed.
our eyes
are opened
our heart
is warmed
and we speak the word of God from the
heart.
So let me ask you a basic question this morning students.
From this end of the room all the way back there.
Have you experienced God?
He said well, I mean I think so. I don't know.
Well, I have good news for you because this leads us to our second reflection.
How do you experience God?
This gets us to the call that saves.
After this outpouring of the spirit this point about
God's spirit being poured out.
We find out how that happens look at it.
Then everyone who calls on the name of the
Lord will be saved for there will be an escape
for those on Mount Zion and in Jerusalem
as the Lord promised amongst the survivors the Lord calls
you see when the day of the Lord comes and that's
what it's talking about.
where God comes to judge the living and the
dead
who's going to survive?
Those who call on God's name.
When we call on the name of the Lord, we are asking
God for help Deliverance instead of
other sources. We think will help.
God's very name call on the name of the
Lord God's very name ensures deliverance and
help because that's who God is
He is the deliverer. He is the savior. He is
the Lord.
And no other name can save.
only his name can save
how do we call or who do we call in times of
trouble?
I tend to call my dad.
My dad's one of my heroes.
In times of trouble. I called my dad that's good.
I have some friends that I call in times of trouble. I have a mentor that
I call in times of trouble.
And what I call their names that I say Dad I need help Jay. I
need help.
Matt I need help.
Guess what happens I get good advice. I get somebody to pray
for me.
But my father my family my mentor and my
friend can't save me.
There's only one day.
That can save there's only one name that can hold life.
and death
there's only one name that can preserve my life
now.
but also for eternity
the very name of God.
Who is the name of the day? What is the name of the Lord? Who is this person
that I'm talking about?
Well in the book of Acts those who call
on the name of the Lord for salvation.
Call on the name of Jesus.
Believing his salvation. We know this because
you know when?
In the book of Acts after Jesus is ascended one of
Jesus's followers a rough guy named Peter.
He starts preaching there at the temple and all the sudden this weird Spirit
thing happens where tongues of
fire appear and everybody's talking and there's all these
different nations and tribes and languages speaking, but because
of these tongues of fire somehow everybody's able to
hear the word of the lord. It's an unbelievable outpouring of
prophecy and
In that moment.
Some of the people who are a little skeptical say everybody's drunk what's
going on?
muttering around what's going on Peter jumps in
verse 14 of chapter 2 and he says
fellow Jews and all you read it residents of Jerusalem. Let me
explain this to you and pay attention to my words for these
people aren't drunk as you suppose. It's only nine
in the morning if they're drunk at 9:00 in the morning. They've got a
problem, right?
On the contrary. This is what was spoken through the prophet Joel.
And then he quotes our passage he says and it will
be in these last days says God that I will pour out my spirit on
all people then your sons and your daughters will prophesy your
young men will see Visions. Your old men will dream dreams. I will
even pour out my spirit on my servants in those days but men and
women and they will prophesy and I will display wonders in the heaven above signs
on the earth below blood and fire and smoke the
sun will be turned to Darkness and the moon to blood before the
great and glorious day of the Lord comes then everyone who calls
on the name of the
Lord will be saved fellow Israelites. Listen to these words. This
Jesus of Nazareth was a man attested to
you by God with Miracles Wonder signs. And
God did among you through him just as yourself no.
Though he was delivered up. According to God's judgment. Did God's
determine play and in foreknowledge. You used Lawless
people to nail him to the cross and kill him. God raised them
up.
Ending the Pains of death because it was not possible for him
to be held by Death.
And then this is what he says.
After he talks about Jesus and what Jesus did he?
Says you need to call on Jesus's name for salvation.
There's only one name that is able to ultimately save
you.
And it's not the name of a university.
It's not the name of a profession or a job. It's not the name of a friend
or a family member. There's only one name that will be your
and look at what Joel says escape from
judgment.
And that's the name.
of Jesus
the name of Jesus
and we are in the time right now where we have
the opportunity to call on the name of Jesus. And
when we do guess what happens the spirit comes and
we experience God and it's not just for
the religious view. It's not just for me who's preaching this
morning. It's for you.
So you can know God.
Like a friend there's only one name that saves.
We can call.
on Jesus's name
Do you know him?
Have you called on the name that saves?
It's the name of Jesus.
When we do my friends we can have the experience of
one of our students.
life transformation
Light behind the eyes rather than when you wake up, it's just
the the worst.
Doldrum. Oh another day. It doesn't have to be that way.
You can break addictions.
You can find purpose and meaning.
you can find forgiveness of sins if
You call in his name?